- Jennifer Aniston, you know, we joke about this thing, but you did actually break the internet
- Uh huh, I broke it - You genuinely did, didn't you?
- I guess I genuinely did, yes, not intentionally - Yeah, but do you know Instagram Julie? - Yes, yes
- So uh, Jennifer joined Instagram and broke it
- That's how, that's how I like to enter -  Would you mind  explaining that because - You're asking the wrong person, but um
I think what happened was too many people at one time. I think it just got clogged. I don't really until somebody agrees on what happened
- Well, you got to a million followers faster than anyone in history
That's what you did
- That's what - Yeah, and so people couldn't, I think people couldn't like or follow things because everyone was just following you at the same time
I think that's what happened - I think, I don't know
- But no, but you started big, you started your very first post. Of course at a Friends reunion. There you all are
(awwing)
And was that like an old picture you've been saving kind of, I'm gonna break Instagram one day
- This is my weapon
- Or was that a recent thing - It's a recent picture - Because, I mean, you guys whenever any of you were here you got to think oh I can't ask them of a Friends reunion
But this is you fanning the flames
- Well this is us, well no, this is just we love to get together whenever we can cause David lives in New York and Matt's working
I mean the girls are, we're very good about keeping up with our - Yeah - Time together
But, so when that happens, we just have so much fun